Shure: （歌词）无话可说
Shure: (lyrics) Nothing to say.
Jake: 今天是谷雨
Jake: Today is Grain Rain.
Shure: 今天还是个节气呢
Shure: It's a solar term today.
Shure: 那吃什么
Shure: So what should we eat?
Shure: 吃饺子吧
Shure: Let's have dumplings.
Lucia: 哈哈哈遇事不决吃饺子
Lucia: Hahaha, when in doubt, eat dumplings.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure: 对啊反正咱也不知道吃什么
Shure: Yeah, since we don't know what to eat anyway.
Jake: 摘谷雨茶走
Jake: Let's pick some Grain Rain tea.
Jake: 谷雨祭海
Jake: Grain Rain, sacrifice to the sea.
Jake: 吃春赏花
Jake: Eat spring, appreciate flowers.
Jake: 什么玩意
Jake: What the heck.
Lucia: 不知道在赏花
Lucia: No idea, appreciating flowers.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: No idea.
Lucia: 咱可以有
Lucia: We can have it.
Shure: 那就吃饺子吧
Shure: Then let's have dumplings.
Jake: 吃饺子行
Jake: Dumplings it is.
Jake: 可以啊中午吃饺子吧
Jake: Sure, let's have dumplings for lunch.
Jake: 要不行
Jake: Or not.
Jake: 妙啊
Jake: Brilliant.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Lucia: 哎遇事不好
Lucia: Hey, things are not good.
Lucia: 咱这有铅笔吗
Lucia: Do we have a pencil?
Jake: 没有铅笔哦
Jake: No pencil, sorry.
Shure: 昨天昨天晚上怎么偷偷发红包呢
Shure: Why did you secretly give out red envelopes last night?
Jake: 那就发工资
Jake: Well, then it's payroll.
Jake: 哎工资还没发完呢
Jake: Ah, the salary isn't fully paid yet.
Lucia: 突然来真的
Lucia: Suddenly being serious.
Shure: 突然变成抢的了
Shure: Suddenly turned into a grab.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 昨天晚上睡亏了
Shure: Slept through the loss last night.
Shure: 睡没一百块钱
Shure: Slept away a hundred bucks.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure: 卧槽这觉睡的
Shure: Damn, that was a good sleep.
Shure: 我从来没感觉我自己一宿这么值钱过
Shure: I've never felt so valuable after a night's sleep.
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.
Shure: （歌词）记得那一首歌
Shure: (Lyrics) Remember that song.
Jake: 那个金币是买的对吧
Jake: Those gold coins were bought, right?
Jake: 嗯嗯金币就是买的贴纸
Jake: Yeah, the gold coins are for buying the stickers.
Lucia: 贴纸对今天到
Lucia: The stickers will arrive today.
Jake: 那我到了OK哦
Jake: Then I'll be there, okay.
Shure: 哦一说到贴纸
Shure: Oh, speaking of stickers...
Shure: 我还有点伴手礼
Shure: I got some small gifts.
Jake: 伴手礼
Jake: Small gifts?
Jake: 当伴郎去了
Jake: Were you a groomsman?
Shure: 什么什么乱梗啊
Shure: What are you talking about?
Jake: 不是啊伴手礼不是这玩意吗
Jake: Aren't small gifts these things?
Katrina:  啥呀
Katrina: What is it?
Shure: 送你
Shure: It's for you.
Katrina:  这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Shure: 这是我们乐队LOGO的贴纸
Shure: These are stickers with our band's logo.
Shure: 哈哈哈周边产品啊
Shure: Haha, it's our merchandise.
Katrina:  你们好正啊
Katrina: You guys are so professional.
Lucia: 你们这个贴纸好客系啊
Lucia: Your stickers are very welcoming.
Shure: 是的这LOGO花3,000块钱设计的呢
Shure: Yeah, the logo design cost 3,000 yuan.
Jake: 为什么不送我啊
Jake: Why didn't you give me one?
Shure: 送的送的
Shure: I did, I did.
Shure: 都送了
Shure: I gave them all out.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 叫什么呀
Jake: What's it called?
Shure: 百鸟辞典
Shure: It's called "Bird Dictionary."
Shure: 这个大概也符合这个元素
Shure: I think it matches the theme.
Shure: 我感觉
Shure: In my opinion.
Jake: 百鸟辞典
Jake: "Bird Dictionary"?
Jake: 为什么呀
Jake: Why?
Jake: 他怎么3
Jake: What does it mean?
Jake: 这这3,000块钱给你什么解释的吗
Jake: Did the 3,000 yuan come with an explanation?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 没有我感觉让GPT生成也差不多
Jake: 不是他他为什么
Jake: But why, why is it...
Jake: 你给我讲讲呗
Jake: Can you explain it to me?
Jake: 这为什么长这样啊
Jake: Why does it look like this?
Shure: 就是哎呀我我我也不会讲
Shure: Well, um, I don't really know how to explain it.
Jake: 他也没给你讲是吧
Jake: He didn't tell you either, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 对我这东西真的只可意会不可言传
Shure: Yeah, this thing is really something you can only understand through experience, not words.
Shure: 看反了看反了这样
Shure: You got it backwards, this way.
Lucia: 雨轩我查了一下如果这样但是
Lucia: Yuxuan, I checked, if it’s like this, but...
Lucia: 如果这个花就是有这个花屁股的话
Lucia: If this flower has this base...
Lucia: 对不起戳到了
Lucia: Sorry, I poked it.
Lucia: 就是花瓣的那个压力就不够
Lucia: The pressure on the petals isn't enough.
Lucia: 因为他这个
Lucia: Because of this...
Lucia: 我就会把那个压的东西托起来一点
Lucia: I would lift the pressing thing a bit.
Lucia: 嗯嗯所以就花瓣就是皱的
Lucia: Uh-huh, so the petals are wrinkled.
Jake: 那我觉得GPT应该能给你画出来
Jake: I think GPT should be able to draw it for you.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 麻烦啊
Lucia: So troublesome.
Shure: 怀念的
Shure: Nostalgic.
Tasha: 我不知道哈哈哈你搜一搜嘛
Tasha: I don't know, haha, why don't you look it up?
Shure: 是无话可说
Shure: Nothing left to say.
Shure: 放点你要听的依某小歌
Shure: Play some of the songs you want to hear.
Shure: it's okay
Shure: It's okay.
Shure: 真的吗别一会放着放着哭了
Shure: Really? Don’t end up crying while listening.
Shure: 咱们的东西都行
Shure: Everything of ours is fine.
Lucia: 今天一会吧
Lucia: Maybe later today.
Lucia: 刚是说什么吃饺子
Lucia: What were you saying about eating dumplings?
Shure: 对今天是个节气
Shure: Yeah, today is a special day.
Shure: 所以不知道吃什么就吃点饺子吧
Shure: So if you don't know what to eat, just have some dumplings.
Shure: 到了吗快递啊
Shure: Has it arrived, the package?
Shure: 快递到了吗
Shure: Has the package arrived?
Katrina:  我的快递还没到
Katrina: My package hasn't arrived yet.
Katrina:  怎么了哎
Katrina: What's up? Hey.
Shure: 你在让GPT干嘛
Shure: Why are you yelling at GPT?
Shure: 我没有呃
Shure: I didn't, uh...
Jake:就问他谷雨吃什么啊
Jake: Just asking what to eat during Guyu.
Jake: 刚刚我在楼上以为下面你们谁在唱
Jake: Just now, I was upstairs and thought someone downstairs was singing.
Jake: 这个唱挺好
Jake: It sounded pretty good.
Shure: 我们还可以KTV
Shure: We can still do KTV.
Katrina:  你这个恰比比心有一点意思
Katrina: Your heart gesture is kind of interesting.
Jake: 我这恰比比啥了
Jake: What did I do with the heart gesture?
Shure: 习俗
Shure: Custom.
Katrina:  好像我教导主任了
Katrina: You sound like my dean.
Jake: 哈哈这么这么带范
Jake: 是豆腐青菜
Shure: 他我感觉是胡作胡弄呵呵呵
Shure: I feel like he's just messing around, haha.
Jake: 我也觉得
Jake: I think so too.
Jake: 这玩意还得上百度
Jake: We need to check Baidu for this.
Shure: 谷歌都不行
Shure: 确实呵
Shure: Indeed, haha.
Shure: 这玩意真真的是百度才能比
Shure: This really needs Baidu to compare.
Shure: 闻要不问文心一言吧
Shure: Or should we ask Wenxin Yiyan?
Jake: 这个确实
Jake: That's true.
Jake: 模板他都写好了
Jake: The template is already written.
Shure: 我好像有
Shure: I think I have it.
Shure: 我还我试一下
Shure: Let me try it.
Shure: 文心
Shure: Wenxin.
Shure: 我靠我没有文心一言
Shure: Oh no, I don't have Wenxin Yiyan.
Shure: 不能啊我记我有了
Shure: No way, I remember having it.
Jake: 还是问百度吧
Jake: Better ask Baidu.
Jake: 小度小度
Jake: Xiaodu, Xiaodu.
Shure: 居然真没有
Shure: I really don't have it.
Shure: 抖音旗下还有个叫豆包的
Shure: Bytedance also has something called Doubao.
Jake: 济仓节
Jake: Ji Cang Festival.
Jake: 喝谷雨茶
Jake: Drink Guyu tea.
Shure: 谷雨茶是啥
Shure: What's Guyu tea?
Shure: 要不咱们点点奶茶吧
Shure: How about we get some milk tea instead?
Shure: 今天哈哈哈
Shure: Today, haha.
Jake: 哈哈哈可以
Jake: Hahaha, sounds good.
Shure: 我靠好久没喝了
Shure: Wow, it's been a while since I had some.
Jake: 二春茶
Jake: Spring tea.
Jake: 一定得是上午采的茶
Jake: It has to be picked in the morning.
Shure: 记得那一首歌
Shure: Remember that song?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 要跨着篮子到野外走来走去就叫走
Jake: You have to carry a basket and walk around in the wild, that's called walking.
Jake: 走谷雨啊那我们就去玩狗去吧
Jake: Walking during Guyu, let's go play with the dog.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 要杀五毒
Jake: Need to kill the five poisons.
Jake: 要看到苍蝇得打这个
Jake: If you see a fly, you have to hit it.
Jake: 这是什么习俗吗
Jake: Is this some kind of tradition?
Shure: 这什么歌
Shure: What song is this?
Shure: 我看我这两天把我的号养成什么样子
Shure: Let's see what I've done with my account these past few days.
Katrina:  呵呵呵养成非摇滚了
Katrina: Hehehe, non-rock style.
Shure: 你为什么用你的号啊啊
Shure: Why are you using your account?
Shure: 换个号换个号
Shure: Change the account, change the account.
Jake: 换个号
Jake: Change the account.
Shure: 没有没有会员啊
Shure: There's no membership on this one.
Jake: 这不算吗
Jake: Doesn't that count?
Jake: 哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, that's how it is.
Jake: 那他也有模式吧
Jake: But it also has modes, right?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake: 那吃8个你吃几个呀
Jake: If you eat 8, how many will you eat?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Jake: 我10个15个
Jake: I can eat 10, maybe 15.
Shure: 十十个吧
Shure: About 10.
Shure: 你就按10个算吧
Shure: Let's just count it as 10.
Jake: 10个行
Jake: 10 is fine.
Jake: 按10个算
Jake: Let's count it as 10.
Jake: 再整点饼
Jake: And some more pancakes.
Jake: 还有那种什么叫叫香椿饼你知道吧
Jake: There are those... what are they called... Xiangchun pancakes, you know?
Shure: 不知道
Shure: No, I don't know.
Shure: 香椿啊香椿我知道
Shure: Xiangchun? Yeah, I know Xiangchun.
Shure: 应该是问你今天能吃几个饺子
Shure: Should I ask how many dumplings you can eat today?
Shure: 100个
Shure: 100.
Jake: 那你不吃
Jake: Then you won't eat.
Jake: 你不吃完不准走
Jake: You can't leave until you finish.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 没看过那个什么那个视频吗
Shure: Haven't you seen that video?
Shure: 那个什么什么
Shure: That... what was it?
Shure: 你感觉今天数学能考多少分
Shure: How many points do you think you'll get on the math test today?
Shure: 80分然后啪下了卷 59分
Shure: 80 points, and then bam, 59.
Shure: 学费了吗
Shure: Tuition?
Katrina: 步骤是一模一样的呀
Katrina: The steps are exactly the same.
Katrina:  结果是完全不一样
Katrina: But the result is completely different.
Shure: 没事你先成功之后
Shure: It's okay, you succeed first.
Shure: 然后教我们好吧
Shure: Then teach us, okay?
Shure: 那谁呢我还能下棋吗
Shure: What about that? Can I still play chess?
Shure: 下棋吗
Shure: Play chess?
Shure: 来下棋
Shure: Come, let's play chess.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 咦
Shure: Eh?
Shure: 那我们就好好下一会哈哈哈
Shure: Then let's play for a while, hahaha.
其他人：放这可以吗
Others: Can we put this here?
Shure: 哎尝尝尝放这吧
Shure: Hey, try it, put it here.
Jake: 要不放二楼去
Jake: Or we could put it on the second floor.
Jake: 放二楼拆吧
Jake: Put it on the second floor and open it.
Jake: 位置大一点放二楼桌上拆吧
Jake: There's more space, let's open it on the second floor table.
Shure: 先放这吧
Shure: Let's put it here first.
Lucia: 要不好一楼用的东西在一楼拆
Lucia: Or maybe open the stuff for the first floor on the first floor.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 杨是
Tasha: Yang is...
Tasha: 杨就是他的呗
Tasha: Yang is his, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Tasha: 他买了绿晶石
Tasha: He bought a green crystal.
Tasha: 不好意思
Tasha: Sorry.
Katrina:  那是我的
Katrina: That’s mine.
Katrina:  没事没事
Katrina: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  我突然想起我好像到了一个
Katrina: I just remembered I got a...
Shure: 精油
Shure: Essential oil.
Shure: 哦我以为要开始SPA了呢
Shure: Oh, I thought we were going to start a spa session.
Shure: 我以为还有这手艺呢哈哈哈
Shure: I thought you had that skill too, hahaha.
Shure: 你看看你看
Shure: Look, look.
Shure: 原来我私人FM从来不会给我推
Shure: My personal FM never recommends me this kind of Mandarin pop.
Shure: 这种华语大流行
Shure: You know?
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: Do you know?
Shure: 咖啡豆
Shure: Coffee beans.
Katrina:  拆快递拆的爽了
Katrina: It's so satisfying to open packages.
Alice: 剪刀嘞
Alice: Where are the scissors?
Katrina: 每个人都在找剪刀
Katrina: Everyone is looking for scissors.
Alice: 也没有小刀呀
Alice: There's no small knife either.
Shure: 有咖啡喝了
Shure: Got coffee to drink.
Shure: 活过来了
Shure: I feel alive.
Shure: 活了
Shure: Alive.
Shure: 有啡子喝了
Shure: okay
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 爽
Shure: Nice.
Shure: 超市他们家出了一个新款
Shure: The supermarket has a new product.
Shure: 你可以尝一尝
Shure: You can try it.
Shure: 可以拿热牛奶
Shure: You can use hot milk.
Shure: 然后直接它类似于那种小的茶包那种
Shure: And then it's like a small tea bag.
Shure: 然后直接丢到那里面
Shure: Just throw it in.
Shure: 然后拿热牛奶或者是
Shure: And then use hot milk or...
Shure: 拿热牛奶泡
Shure: Give him warm milk.
Shure: 他就不苦了
Shure: 这什么我修
Shure: What is this? I'll fix it.
Lucia: 我修我修过
Lucia: I'll fix it, I've done it before.
Lucia: 我修电脑干过最大的工程
Lucia: The biggest project I've done while fixing a computer
Lucia: 就是给自己加装内存条
Lucia: was adding more RAM to it.
Lucia: 剩下我啥都不敢干
Lucia: I don't dare do anything else.
Lucia: 因为我要是拆了我就装不回去了
Lucia: Because if I take it apart, I can't put it back together.
Jake: 当时为了换了几个键盘键
Jake: One time, I just replaced a few keyboard keys.
Jake: 然后把整个MAC给拆了
Lucia: 但是您把它拆了还得组装成台式机
Lucia: But after you took it apart, you had to put it back together as a desktop.
Lucia: 这我真没想到
Lucia: I didn't expect that.
Lucia: 怎么凭空还多了一些零件呢
Lucia: How did you end up with extra parts out of nowhere?
Jake: 没有就是屏幕散开
Jake: No, the screen just came apart.
Lucia: 就是装回去发现零件多了
Lucia: So when you put it back together, you found extra parts?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice: 香椿饼是你点的吗
Alice: Did you order the Chinese toon pancake?
Shure: 这是啥呀
Shure: What's this?
Shure: 不是不是吗
Shure: Isn't it?
Jake: 呃算是呃
Jake: Uh, kind of, uh...
Jake: 百度文心一言都没开
Shure: 他他他问百度的
Shure: He, he, he asked Baidu.
Jake: 对只能问百度
Jake: Yeah, only Baidu knows.
Shure: 说谷雨要吃啥就是啊
Shure: They say you should eat something special for Grain Rain.
Tasha: 香椿饼啊
Tasha: Chinese toon pancake!
Jake: 对他没说饺子
Jake: Yeah, he didn't say dumplings.
Jake: 但是我们还是点
Jake: But we still ordered them.
Shure: 因为饺子总不会错的
Shure: Because you can never go wrong with dumplings.
Shure: 毕竟好吃不过饺子
Shure: After all, nothing tastes better than dumplings.
Alice: 我还以为香椿饼是专门点的
Alice: I thought the Chinese toon pancake was specially ordered.
Jake: 就是是是专门点的就是
Jake: It was, it was specially ordered.
Shure: 就为了今天这个节气
Shure: Just for today’s solar term.
Jake: 对问了百度说今儿应该吃点啥
Jake: Yeah, Baidu said we should eat something specific today.
Jake: 今天还有叫逛谷雨还是走
Jake: 谷雨什么呀
Jake: 走谷雨
Shure: 对要拿着篮子
Shure: Yeah, you have to carry a basket.
Shure: 然后出出去溜达一圈
Shure: And then go out for a walk.
Tasha: 那我要拿那个
Tasha: Then I’ll take that.
Katrina:  那我们去撸狗吧
Katrina: Then let’s go walk the dog.
Shure: 对我们就拿着这个
Shure: Yeah, we'll just take this.
Shure: 然后唱着采蘑菇的小姑娘
Shure: And then sing "The Little Mushroom Picker."
Shure: 可能看到你伤心了吧
Shure: Maybe because you look sad.
Katrina:  我没伤心白天跟晚上是两个人
Katrina: I'm not sad. I'm a different person day and night.
Shure: 哭哭哭
Shure: Cry, cry, cry.
Shure: 听点EMO的小日文歌
Shure: Listen to some emo Japanese songs.
Shure: 这是一个特别好看的纯爱日剧
Shure: This is a really beautiful pure love Japanese drama.
Shure: 我跟你讲我靠
Shure: Let me tell you, man.
Shure: 叫做黄昏时分牵着手
Shure: It's called "Holding Hands at Dusk."
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 讲的是那个男主就是是一个做音乐的
Shure: It's about the male lead who's a musician.
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Shure: 然后就是就是反正偶然机遇
Shure: Anyway, by chance...
Shure: 就被那种大唱片公司签了
Shure: He got signed by a big record company.
Shure: 然后就开始然后跟女主邂逅
Shure: And then he met the female lead.
Shure: 是他正好住到了这
Shure: He just happened to move here.
Shure: 完了我这概括能力好好差
Shure: Man, my summarizing skills are so bad.
Shure: 然后反正就是
Shure: Anyway, it’s just...
Shure: 他们两个各自都有各自的一个长处
Shure: They each have their own strengths.
Shure: 然后那种特别健康的那种
Shure: And they are both really healthy.
Shure: 两个人都那什么
Shure: Both of them are like that.
Shure: 摁压
Shure: Press down.
Shure: 顶上我给你照一张来
Shure: I'll take a picture from the top.
Katrina:  我不要
Katrina: I don't want to.
Katrina:  但他们说还可以烤他
Katrina: But they said it can also be roasted.
Shure: 是能吃的
Shure: It's edible.
Shure: 能炸
Shure: You can fry it.
Shure: 其实玉兰花炸的好像据说很好吃
Shure: Actually, fried magnolia is said to be really tasty.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 市级吗
Shure: City-level?
Jake: 刚刚这波数据挺离谱的
Jake: Those numbers just now were wild.
Jake: 上面招呼招呼我就出现了
Jake: They just called me up, and I showed up.
Shure: 是的你看
Shure: Yeah, look.
Shure: 我得给大家看一眼
Shure: I need to show everyone.
Shure: 你出现了
Shure: You showed up.
Shure: 然后他没看到
Shure: And he didn't see it.
Shure: 杨老板要尝试一下吗
Shure: Jake, wanna give it a try?
Shure: 来泡杯咖啡喝
Shure: Let's make some coffee.
Shure: 来我来
Shure: Let me do it.
Shure: 必须
Shure: Absolutely.
Jake:这专业的
Jake: This is professional.
Shure: 就是分毫不差
Shure: Not a fraction off.
Jake:这一杯卖多少钱
Jake: How much does this cup sell for?
Shure: 这一杯你要去咖啡店啊
Shure: If you go to a coffee shop...
Shure: 五六十起就是10新币哦
Shure: It starts at fifty to sixty, which is around 10 SGD.
Jake:不是国内的10新币
Jake: Not 10 SGD domestically.
Jake:国内的五六十
Jake: Fifty to sixty domestically.
Shure: 对国内的五六十
Shure: Yeah, fifty to sixty domestically.
Jake:国内五六十搁新加坡就得20多
Jake: Fifty to sixty domestically would be over 20 in Singapore.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 那不是这
Shure: That's not it.
Shure: 这个好像全球都一个价好像
Shure: This seems to be the same price globally.
Jake:那也差不多嗯
Jake: Yeah, more or less.
Shure: 15克的豆子
Shure: 15 grams of beans.
Shure: 然后我们这次就是每次我跟你讲
Shure: So, this time, as I was saying...
Shure: 就是一般首充的话他们会给你讲一下
Shure: Generally, for the first charge, they'll tell you...
Shure: 会给你个小卡片
Shure: They'll give you a small card.
Shure: 然后就是印着这些信息
Shure: And it has all this info printed on it.
Shure: 这是一个什么圭
Shure: This is a Guatemalan...
Shure: 下的一个日晒的豆子
Shure: Sun-dried bean.
Shure: 然后他是一个浅度烘焙的
Shure: It's a light roast.
Shure: 然后风味概述主要有以下这些
Shure: The flavor profile includes these notes.
Jake:就是他建议你做这玩意啊
Jake: So, they recommend you make it like this?
Shure: 不是他是能尝出来有这些味道
Shure: No, they just say you can taste these flavors.
Shure: 哦那蜂蜜柚子茶他是怎么弄进去的
Shure: Oh, how did they get the honey grapefruit tea flavor in there?
Shure: 就是他本来就有那个味道
Shure: It naturally has that flavor.
Shure: 可能是然后就用了一个这个形容词
Shure: Maybe they just used that description.
Shure: 对对对
Shure: Yeah, exactly.
Jake: 多少克
Jake: How many grams?
Shure: 15克哎呦我操
Shure: 15 grams. Whoa, damn.
Shure: 往回倒哈哈哈
Shure: Pour some back, hahaha.
Shure: 还是多了点
Shure: Still a bit too much.
Shure: 往回放点
Shure: Put some back.
Shure: 失误了完了
Shure: Made a mistake, it's over.
Shure: 杨老板一看我
Shure: Jake's watching me.
Shure: 我整不会了
Shure: I can’t do this anymore.
Shure: 然后给尝试操作一下
Shure: Then, give it a try.
Shure: 就是
Shure: So...
Shure: 对往这边
Shure: Yes, this way.
Jake:这么带劲对
Jake: So energetic, right.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Jake:开过拖拉机吗
Jake: Have you ever driven a tractor?
Shure: 没有什么择偶标准
Shure: No, any preferences for a partner?
Shure: 要会手摇拖拉机是吧
Shure: Should be able to hand-crank a tractor, right?
Shure: 拖拉机打火就要这么摇
Shure: You have to crank it like this to start the tractor.
Shure: 快好了OK
Shure: Almost done, OK.
Shure: 对这是摇完了
Shure: Yes, it's finished cranking.
Shure: 然后下一步把这个秤调到auto模式
Shure: Next step, set this scale to auto mode.
Jake: 为啥要auto
Jake: Why auto?
Shure: 呃就是它可以自动计时会
Shure: Uh, it can automatically time things.
Shure: 会方便一点
Shure: Makes it a bit easier.
Jake:它计时了吗
Jake: Is it timing now?
Shure: 他没有没
Shure: No, not yet.
Shure: 他一会注水才开始计时
Shure: 然后这是滤纸
Shure: And this is the filter paper.
Shure: 就是把咖啡渣滤出去的
Shure: It's for filtering out the coffee grounds.
Jake:他们谁说用咖啡渣做什么东西的啊
Jake: Someone mentioned using coffee grounds for something, right?
Shure: 对那个东西其实可以当肥料什么的
Shure: Yes, they can actually be used as fertilizer and stuff.
Jake: 他们好像说
Jake: They seem to say...
Shure: 把他拧出来
Shure: Squeeze it out.
Shure: 然后倒进去
Shure: Then pour it in.
Jake:做做装饰品这玩意
Jake: Make some decorations with this thing.
Shure: 嗯前几天发现也行
Shure: Hmm, discovered that a few days ago, it works too.
Shure: 刚烧开的
Shure: Just boiled.
Shure: 差不多就是这个 92度
Shure: It's about 92 degrees, close enough.
Jake:这92度问题是答对了
Jake: This 92 degrees is correct.
Shure: 官方建议
Shure: Official recommendation.
Shure: 你真的就跟我答答辩
Shure: You're really answering like an exam.
Shure: 老师你这个是怎么知道
Shure: Teacher, how did you know?
Shure: 我说百百度
Shure: I said Baidu.
Shure: 百度搜的
Shure: Searched on Baidu.
Shure: 让让我这么做的对
Shure: Told me to do it this way, right.
Jake: 为啥用这个
Jake: Why use this?
Jake: 参数就是
Jake: Parameters are...
Shure: 然后你就可以拿着然后开始操作的
Shure: Then you can hold it and start the operation.
Shure: 来吧尝试一下
Shure: Come on, give it a try.
Jake:到多少
Jake: How much?
Shure: 倒到大概50克左右
Shure: Pour about 50 grams.
Shure: 先转转一圈这样
Shure: First, spin it around like this.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: OK收
Shure: OK, got it.
Shure: 然后50克子
Shure: Then 50 grams.
Shure: 没事第一
Shure: It's fine, first
Shure: 第一步叫做闷蒸
Shure: The first step is called blooming.
Shure: 闷蒸就是
Shure: Blooming means
Jake:闷蒸
Jake: Blooming.
Shure: 让他这个气体稍微
Shure: Letting a bit of carbon dioxide out.
Shure: 排出来一点二氧化碳
Shure: Then let it bloom for about 30 seconds.
Shure: 然后大概焖蒸30秒
Shure: This helps release its aroma.
Shure: 就是把它的这个香味先激发出来
Shure: You can smell it.
Jake:哦能闻到
Jake: Oh, I can smell it.
Shure: 能闻到吧能闻到
Shure: You can smell it, right?
Shure: 然后之后继续
Shure: Then continue.
Shure: 继续拿下来
Shure: Continue pouring.
Shure: 继续
Shure: Continue.
Shure: 然后一慢慢的一圈一圈
Shure: Slowly, in circles.
Shure: 然后最后倒到240
Shure: Finally, pour up to 240 grams.
Shure: 慢慢的再慢点也可以
Shure: You can go slower if you want.
Shure: 就一圈一圈
Shure: Just in circles.
Jake:在哪学的这玩意
Jake: Where did you learn this?
Shure: 买了本书啊
Shure: Bought a book.
Jake:然后呢那器具你是也是根据书买的
Jake: And the equipment? Did you get it based on the book too?
Shure: 呃也不是呃
Shure: Uh, not really, uh.
Shure: 这就是找一些视频
Shure: Just watched some videos.
Shure: 然后看推荐什么的
Shure: And checked recommendations.
Shure: 再稍微快一点也可以
Shure: You can go a bit faster too.
Jake:他不能有泡啊
Jake: No bubbles, right?
Jake:还是不讲究
Jake: Or does it not matter?
Shure: 嗯没那么讲究
Shure: Yeah, it's not that strict.
Jake:240 对
Jake: 240 grams, right.
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Almost there.
Shure: 可以了
Shure: It's good.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 然后等水滤完
Shure: Then wait for the water to filter.
Shure: 然后就OK了
Shure: And it's done.
Shure: 这就是
Shure: This is
Shure: 他这个冲煮方式有很多
Shure: There are many brewing methods.
Shure: 刚刚那种就叫一刀流
Shure: The one we just did is called "single pour".
Shure: 就是闷蒸之后
Shure: So after steaming
Shure: 然后一直倒一直倒一直倒
Shure: You keep pouring, keep pouring, keep pouring
Shure: 倒到240
Shure: Pour until 240
Shure: 还有还有什么三段式几段法那种
Shure: And there are these three-stage or multi-stage methods
Jake:会有什么差别吗
Jake: Will there be any difference?
Shure: 他确实会不一样
Shure: There definitely will be
Shure: 但你究竟哪种好喝
Shure: But which one tastes better
Shure: 这也说不出来
Shure: It's hard to say
Shure: 反正他肯定是是能有不一样的
Shure: Anyway, there will definitely be differences
Jake: 但是这个优势就是这个
Jake: But this advantage is this
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:这个优势明显
Jake: This advantage is obvious
Shure: 对明显
Shure: Yes, obvious
Shure: sum up
Shure: 大哥先喝
Shure: You drink first, bro
Shure: 哈哈好
Shure: Haha, alright
Shure: 你们带货开始是吧哈哈
Shure: You guys are starting to sell things, right? Haha
Shure: 这个怎么滴的这么慢
Shure: Why is this dripping so slow?
Shure: 其实差不多了
Shure: Actually, it's almost done
Shure: 拿个杯子
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Jake: 哎要补点杯子
Jake: Hey, we need to add some cups
Shure: 咱们给他补了个水壶了都哈哈哈
Shure: We already added a kettle for him, haha
Shure: 这一杯就差不多
Shure: This cup is almost enough
Jake:他这个还是往下流吗
Jake: Is it still flowing down?
Shure: 还是还是还在往下流
Shure: Yes, it's still flowing down
Jake:还是
Jake: Still?
Shure: 但是他流
Shure: But it's flowing
Shure: 对谢谢你
Shure: Yes, thank you
Jake:谢谢你
Jake: Thank you
Shure: 没事这你看就是有一个尖这个
Shure: No problem, see there's a pointy thing here
Shure: 然后放到这
Shure: Then place it here
Shure: OK
Jake:配点奶
Jake: Add some milk
Jake:配吗这个
Jake: Add milk to this?
Shure: 这个一般不配
Shure: This one generally doesn't get milk
Shure: 因为它是稀的对
Shure: Because it's thin, right
Shure: 嗯很磁式
Shure: Hmm, it's very magnetic
Shure: 这个东西
Shure: This thing
Shure: 挡着那什么
Shure: Blocking that thing
Shure: 他们这个尤其这个东西可可多讲究了
Shure: They really pay attention to the details with this stuff.
Shure: 猜猜这个小东西多少钱
Shure: Guess how much this little thing costs.
Jake:这个啊我靠
Jake: This? Oh my god...
Jake:我可猜不出几百啊 300块
Jake: I can't guess, maybe a few hundred? 300 bucks?
Shure: 啊 300块
Shure: Yeah, 300 bucks.
Shure: 但是这个东西还网上还有贵的
Shure: But you can find even more expensive ones online.
Shure: 就是什么里面的刀头会怎么怎么样
Shure: Like, the blades inside do something special...
Shure: 更好切了
Shure: They cut better.
Shure: 就是切出来的粉更均匀
Shure: The powder it produces is more uniform.
Shure: 更均匀就是保证每个颗粒的大小
Shure: More uniform means the size of each particle is...
Shure: 几乎是一样的
Shure: Almost identical.
Jake:呵呵确实讲究
Jake:但是就是那种大机器
Shure: 大机器也也有讲究
Shure: Big machines have their own details too.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Like...
Jake:反正那个大机器它应该做的更均匀
Jake: Anyway, those big machines should make it more uniform.
Shure: 也不一定
Shure: Not necessarily.
Shure: 你要不好的它它也不行
Shure: If you get a bad one, it doesn't work well either.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 这是这是你的
Shure: This is yours.
Shure: 不好意思
Shure: Sorry.
Shure: 哎我那杯放哪了
Shure: Hey, where did I put my cup?
Shure: 这啊这
Shure: Oh, here it is.
Jake: 是一个味吗
Jake: Does it taste the same?
Shure: 差不多
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure: 差的是凉了点的
Shure: The difference is it's a bit colder.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 感觉纯答辩
Jake: Feels like we're just arguing.
Jake: 哈哈哈是很像啊
Jake: Hahaha, it really does.
Shure: 哈哈哈没有没有哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, no, no, hahaha.
Jake: 去微环节
Jake: Let's move on.
Jake: 这个可是插哪了
Jake: Where should we plug this in?
Shure: 然后那个
Shure: And then...
Shure: 对而且Andy他说话有有很多有口音
Shure: Yeah, and Andy has a strong accent when he speaks.
Shure: 他那个y w h y y嘛那词
Shure: Like with words that have "y w h y y" sounds.
Shure: why why why you do that
Shure: Why why why you do that.
Shure: why you do that
Shure: Why you do that.
Jake: 哎呀快递饺子来了
Jake: Oh, the dumplings from the delivery are here.
Jake: 应该端下去喝你好
Jake: We should take them down and eat them.
Jake: 哎好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 来了稍等啊
Jake: I'm here, hang on a sec.
Jake: 来了
Jake: I'm here.
Jake:吃饺子
Jake: Let's eat dumplings.
Shure: 好嘞
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 借过一下谢谢
Shure: Excuse me, thanks.
Jake: 路亚你觉得要动吗
Jake: Nicous, do you think we need to move this?
Jake: 这些箱子可能还得用吧
Jake: We might still need these boxes, right?
Jake: 我们都留着
Jake: We'll keep them all.
Jake: 行我们都留着吧
Jake: Okay, we'll keep them all.
Lucia: 也不用都我看一眼
Lucia: We don't need to keep all of them, let me take a look.
Alice: 卢亚那个泡沫箱能帮我拆一下吗
Alice: Nicous, can you help me take apart that foam box?
Shure: 好像也有
Shure: I think there are some too.
Alice: 对
Alice: Yes.
Shure: 不多不多
Shure: Not too many, not too many.
其他人：那个屋的那个屋有人吗
Others: Is there anyone in that room?
Shure: 哪个屋这个屋
Shure: Which room, this room?
其他人：这个屋
Others: This room.
Shure: 这个屋能进吧
Shure: Can we go in this room?
Shure: 他不在里面对
Shure: He's not inside, right?
Alice: 阿姨那个没人可以进去
Alice: Auntie, no one is there, you can go in.
其他人：可以进啊
Others: You can go in.
Alice: 你这个是你们的设计的LOGO吗
Alice: Is this your designed logo?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice: 是这是鸟上长了个柳树的意思吗
Alice: Does this mean a bird growing a willow tree?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Alice: 这不是一个鸟吗
Alice: Isn't this a bird?
Shure: 是鸟对
Shure: It's a bird, yes.
Alice: 这是柳树吗
Alice: Is this a willow tree?
Shure: 这大概就是那种比较克苏鲁的感觉
Shure: It's kind of like that Cthulhu vibe.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure: 不是柳树
Shure: Not a willow tree.
Shure: 是那个类似于一个一个孩子那种感觉
Shure: It's more like a child sort of feeling.
Shure: 你懂吗
Shure: You get it?
Shure: 因为它叫百鸟词典
Shure: Because it's called the Hundred Birds Dictionary.
Jake: 一般是多少啊
Jake: Usually how much is it?
Jake: 我不太懂
Jake: I don't really know.
Katrina:  刚刚那个谁微微看的是一百多一套
Katrina: Just now, Tasha said it's over 100 per set.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Katrina:  100多一套的六套的话那100多 100
Katrina: If it's over 100 per set and you have six sets, that's over 1,000.
Katrina:  多那就是1,000
Katrina: So that's 1,000.
Jake: 就是
Jake: So...
Shure:  100新币了
Shure: It's 100 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 六六百 600多
Jake: That's around 600.
Jake: 什么样的
Jake: What kind of...
Jake: 600多
Jake: About 600.
Jake: 我我瞅瞅去
Jake: Let me go take a look.
Katrina:  哎他在这
Katrina: Hey, he's here.
Jake: 来瞅一瞅你们的衣服
Jake: Let's take a look at your clothes.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 喂喂你到了是吗哎
Shure: Hey, hey, have you arrived?
Shure: 啊你到了你就跟他说是
Shure: Ah, when you arrive, just tell him...
Shure: 那个是来约的今天录歌的
Shure: That you're here to record a song today.
Shure: 旅游的那
Shure: For tourism...
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Shure: 就按我给你的伴奏录就行
Shure: Just record according to the accompaniment I gave you.
Shure: 你要有有有
Shure: If you have...
Shure: 这个水平可以的
Shure: This level is fine.
Shure: 你不行你就录单单声道也行
Shure: If not, just record in mono, it's fine.
Shure: 就是录你女鬼
Shure: Just record your part.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我就不肩膀了今天
Shure: I won't shoulder it today.
Shure: 哈哈好嘞好嘞
Shure: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Shure: 拜拜辛苦你
Shure: Bye bye, thanks for your hard work.
Alice: 它的原理是
Alice: Its principle is...
Alice: 就是让这些容易吸水的材质
Alice: To let these absorbent materials...
Alice: 把它的水分吸干
Alice: Absorb all the moisture.
Alice: 或者搜一下附近有没有什么拍照的
Alice: Or search if there's any photo studio nearby.
Alice: 什么写真馆的
Alice: Like a portrait studio.
Alice: 他们那种礼服
Alice: They have those kinds of dresses.
Tasha: 或者这个
Tasha: Or this one...
Katrina:  没办法这个必须要做点手工活
Katrina: No choice, we need to do some handiwork.
Katrina:  我们要环保
Katrina: We need to be environmentally friendly.
Alice:附近有这店
Alice: There's a shop nearby.
Alice: 可以点歌吗
Alice: Can we request a song?
Shure: 可以可以
Shure: Sure, sure.
Alice: 可以我想听蝴蝶
Alice: I'd like to hear "Butterfly."
Katrina:  蝴蝶我也想听蝴蝶
Katrina: Butterfly, I want to hear it too.
Tasha: 我来帮你吧
Tasha: Let me help you.
Lucia: 就是他带一个抽屉
Lucia: It has a drawer.
Lucia: 所以他会边上要
Lucia: So it needs to be on the side.
Jake: 走吧吃饺子去
Jake: Let's go eat dumplings.
Katrina:  去二楼吃饺子吗
Katrina: Are we going to the second floor to eat dumplings?
Jake: 二楼吃饺子
Jake: Second floor for dumplings.
Tasha: 到了吗
Tasha: Are we there yet?
Jake: 对冰箱也可以
Jake: Yes, the fridge is fine too.
Alice: 我们吃饭的时候需要录吗呃
Alice: Do we need to record while we eat?
Jake: 呃吃饭录着吧
Jake: Uh, let's record while eating.
Lucia: 就是他是一个
Lucia: I mean, he's a...
Jake: 嗯那这个就合理了起来
Jake: Hmm, now this makes sense.
Jake: 突然makesense
Jake: Suddenly, it makes sense.
Katrina:  是那个杨笑脸谁的
Katrina: Is that Yang's smiley face?
Jake: 蝴蝶风铃我的
Jake: The butterfly wind chime is mine.
Katrina: 我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 中央银行
Jake: Central Bank.
Lucia: 哦我明白了这好像也不是那么难搞
Lucia: Oh, I get it. This isn't that hard to handle.
Tasha: 通州区演出服装租赁
Tasha: Costume rental in Tongzhou district.
Jake: 这个好甚至我们可以去挑啊
Jake: This is good, we can even go and pick.
Jake: 如果不远的话
Jake: If it's not far.
Jake: 我们
Jake: We...
Jake: 不远的话下午我们打个车去挑衣服
Jake: If it's not far, we can take a cab in the afternoon to choose clothes.
Jake: 都可以
Jake: That's fine.
Alice: 为什么不能打个车去买衣服
Alice: Why can't we just take a cab to buy clothes?
Alice: 哈哈哈没关系我只是随便说说
Alice: Haha, it's okay, I was just saying.
Jake: 到到时候算算
Jake: We'll figure it out then.
Jake: 算一算看看这打车费加上这多少钱
Jake: Let's calculate and see how much the cab fare would be.
Jake: 打折费应该到不了1,000
Jake: The discount fare shouldn't reach 1,000.
Lucia: 财务人员的一项工作
Lucia: One of the tasks of financial staff.